bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8
nouvelle édition en direct pour débuter
cette semaine en direct à 18h si vous
venez de nous rejoindre et nous
parlerons éducation ce soir avec la
nouvelle présidente du pôle de recherche
et d'enseignement de l'université à
paris grant west anne sophie barthet ce
bonsoir à vous vous nous expliquerez
dans un instant vos priorités et surtout
les enjeux pour se pressent comme on
l'appelle se presse qui regroupe
notamment l'université de cergy
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines vous en est la présidente
depuis le 17 décembre dernier après le
départ de sylvie faucheux elle a été
nommée rectrice de dijon souvenez-vous
nous verrons aussi peu du côté et des
restos du coeur l'inquiétude grandit
face à une demande toujours plus forte
le vice président de l'antenne
départementale viendra également nous
rejoindre et puis le sport le 7-8 ce
sport nouveau rendez vous hebdomadaire
26 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité avec anthony rech
aux alentours de 18 heures 25 si vous me
suivez en direct ce soir bonsoir anthony
bonsoir wilfried et pour ce tout premier
set 8 sport de l'année nous en garderons
dans le rétroviseur évidemment la saison
je recevrai le président du football
club de trappes mustapha larbaoui le
club vient de fêter ses 80 ans et change
de cap avec un nouveau nom qui fait déjà
beaucoup parler et nous ne nous
arrêterons aussi un sur le parcours
exceptionnel des féminines de
voisins-le-bretonneux en tennis de table
qui viennent d'enchaîner deux montées
successives et comme d'habitude en fin
d'émission tous les résultats du week
end
tous les résultats à suivre ce soir le
7-8 sport le reste de l'actualité du
jour en images à présent les principaux
titres les sujets qui seront développées
reportage à découvrir le comité
d'entreprise extraordinaire de
cette tenue ce lundi l enseigne compte
26 magasins en france dont le sol dans
les yvelines se situe à montigny le
bretonneux
les salariés du groupe restent mobilisés
ils manifesteront le mercredi 9 janvier
ce week end les gourmands ont dégusté la
galette l'épiphanie c'est avant tout une
fête religieuse nous avons rencontré les
fidèles réunis ce dimanche en la
cathédrale saint-louis de versailles le
club de football de trappes change de
nom anthony vous le disais dorénavant le
trap 51 football club s'appelle l'étoile
sportive de trappes
c'est en réalité son premier nom une
volonté du président du club mustapha
l'art bruit pour dit-il revenir aux
valeurs fondamentales mais également
protester contre les baisses de
subventions de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines portrait et
enfin de l'équipe première féminine de
tennis de table de voisins-le-bretonneux
qui a enchaîné deux montées en un an et
demi pour évoluer maintenant en
nationale 2 voilà pour le sport le sort
des salariés de virgin à présent suspens
le sait le comité d'entreprise consacré
au dépôt de bilan de l'enseignent elle
va se poursuivre demain mardi en
présence du principal actionnaire cette
fois ci en fin d'après midi aujourd'hui
lundi les syndicats sont restés
déterminés à trouver une solution pour
les quelques 1000 salariés de
l'entreprise des explications le point
complet avec quatre nuls à tôt lundi le
comité d'entreprise de virgin s'est
réunie comme prévu pour débattre du
projet de cessation de paiement de
l'entreprise
un comité qui a été suspendue en début
d'après midi et doit reprendre demain
mardi en présence de l'actionnaire
majoritaire butler capital la société
d'investissement française contrôle le
groupe depuis 2008 et pour les syndicats
c'est le principal responsable
on va déjà demander pourquoi les plus
sains quand on exclut pas réellement
investi dans l'entreprise
il faut savoir que bon sous le sous la
barre de leur capital partners est
sévère très peu de magasins déjà il y
avait pas non plus d'investissements
afin de demain cuir
comment dire william correspondant
quelque peu aux attentes de la clientèle
de l'inquiétude également de l'amertume
parce que effectivement on s'achemine
certainement vers la fin de virgin
megastore et un entreprises qui étaient
implantés en france est intéressant de
bijoux depuis la fin des années 80 voilà
avec jusque dans les années fastes
qu'elle demande de l'unps scénario et
maintenant nous sommes plus que 1 2 puis
c'est tout parmi les 26 magasins virgin
exploité en france un seul dans les
yvelines situé dans le centre commercial
sqy ouest à montigny le magasin a ouvert
ses portes en 2005 il compte une
trentaine de salariés sur leur blog les
salariés franciliens appel à manifester
mercredi 9 janvier devant le magasin
emblématique des champs elysées et nous
reviendrons sur cette situation des
magasins des vers du nez puis le sort
des salariés également dans nos
prochaines éditions notamment demain à
l'université paris-i grant west qui
regroupe des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
de l'ouest de l'île de france prend un
nouveau départ lancé le 6 février 2012
une nouvelle présidente et vient déjà
d'être élu en décembre dernier anne
sophie barthet ce vous succéder dont
cassivi faucheuse elle a été nommée
rectrice de l'académie de dijon ce qui
explique son départ
et justement est ce qu'on peut parler de
nouveau départ pour se pressent presse
logo universités par et grant west
alors on ne peut pas véritablement
parler nouveau départ parce que je
m'inscris vraiment dans la continuité de
ce cas de ce qu'a fait de ce qu'on fait
d'ailleurs sylvie faucheux et françoise
moulin civil pendant pendant quelques
mois
c'est la vice présidente qui était la
vice présidente pardon du prêt ce go
donc je n'ai pas un nouveau départ c'est
une continuité et une volonté forte de
donner à ce prêt ce qui vient naître une
visibilité et à ses membres un
rayonnement qui n'auraient peut-être pas
s'il ne se regroupaient pas au sein de
ce pôle de recherche et d'enseignement
supérieur ça va pas de déstabiliser
le presse justement le regroupement
d'avoir un changement à opérer aussi
rapidement pour la présidence c'était
prévu voilà ce n'était pas prévu ce qui
l'était c'était doublement pas prévu ni
le départ de françoise moulin civil donc
vice présidente qui est légalement a été
nommée rectrice de l'académie de lyon ni
celui quelques semaines plus tard de ses
vies fauchées au sein de l'académie de
dijon
nos statuts ne prévoyait pas cette
vacance est double vacance à la tête de
l'exécutif du presse mais très
rapidement nous sommes retrouvés entre
membres qui comme toujours comme depuis
le départ souhaite collaborer et mener à
terme des projets innovants structurants
et voilà ça m'a pas déstabilisé stabile
les différents projets livre la volonté
de chaque membre est toujours là forte
et engagée au sein de ce presse on va
voir vos priorités pour les prochains
mois on va parler des missions aussi du
prez pour le pour le grand public et les
uns peut faire encore un peu de
pédagogie se pressait et tout nouveau
c'est une création de l'université est
donc cergy pontoise et l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines il
ya des membres associés on peut citer
l'école nationale supérieure
d'architecturé de versailles l'école
supérieure des techniques aéronautiques
et de construction automobile
en tout 13 instituts sont membres à
travers ce grand ouest pourquoi
justement avoir voulu fédérer tous ses
moyens
pourquoi avoir décidé de vous regrouper
et centre presse alors on a décidé de se
regrouper parce qu'on se on s'est dit
qu'on ferait mieux à 13 que seul et que
parfois nous étions voisins sans nous
connaître suffisamment voir sans nous
connaître du tout et que ce prêt c'était
l'occasion de gagner en transversalité
en force en moyens et en intelligence
finalement puisque c'est un regroupement
d'acteurs et enseignement supérieur qui
souhaite avancer qu'ils souhaitent faire
gagner l'université française encore une
fois en compétences en visibilité
internationale
ça permet de faire des économies mais
aussi peut-être certains cas c'est
souvent le mot coordonnées mutualisant
qui revient du prince
oui ça permet de faire des économies
mais ça permet surtout en tout cas dans
un premier temps de faire émerger des
projets qui ne pourraient pas voir le
jour s'il était porté par un
établissement seul alors justement parmi
ces différents projets il ya lieu pc
l'institut d'études politiques ce serait
le dise
en france va voir le jour normalement la
rentrée 2013 créé cet ep c'était
véritablement aussi une demande très
forte nécessaires pour répondre
justement cette demande vous avez décidé
de mettre en place alors lieu paix c'est
un projet extrêmement ambitieux peut y
croyez au départ nous espérons nous
pensons qu'il verra le jour à la rentrée
2013 à la rentrée peut-être 2013 dès la
rentrée 2013
alors pourquoi un nouvel ep pourquoi un
dixième mieux p pour deux raisons la
première c'est qu'il ya une forte
demande
la moitié des étudiants en vain des
lycéens qui se présentent aux concours
des irp et viennent d'île de france
moins de 10% d'entre réussissez concours
donc forte demande c'est la première
raison est la seconde raison c'est que
nous souhaitons faire un ep qui ne
ressemble pas aux autres
un vieux paix renouveler un lieu pas
nouvelle formule nouvelles formes alors
nouvelle formation parce que des publics
divers que l'on va aller chercher dans
des territoires qui quand par exemple
voilà on banlieue nous nous avons déjà
monté un certain nombre de partenariats
avec des lycées de zones fragiles
partenariat pour que soit créé au sein
de ces lycées des préparations concours
des yeux paix pour que des lycéens qui
encore une fois ont les compétences mais
n'ont pas toujours l'idée l'ambition de
présenter ces concours bien de les
présenter dès présentées dans de très
bonnes conditions donc des publics
divers que l'on va aller chercher c'est
la première originalité et la seconde
c'est une coloration comment dire
pédagogiques c'est-à-dire ses tubes et
sera fortement axée vers les politiques
territoriales politique de la ville
gouvernance territoriale ce qui n'est
pas le cas de tous les autres
ep à 150 places en première année 150
places en première année au bout du
compte c'est à dire au bout de cinq ans
800 étudiants environ avec de vrais
débouchés justement parce que vous
parliez d'aller chercher justement aussi
ces jeunes de faire venir un public qui
ne venait pas mais c'est très bien les
former s qu'ensuite ils vont trouver
véritablement du travail et c'est alors
ils vont trouver du travail ils vont
d'autant plus on trouvait que lorsque la
cinquième année se déroulera dans des
masters qui sont déjà existants sein d
université de versailles saint quentin
et cergy-pontoise donc c'est donc bien
fonctionné en voilà ça en ré mineur qui
ont déjà fait leurs preuves en termes
d'insertion professionnelle donc il y
aura ce fameux presse avec ses
différents projets on va continuer à
parler tous ces projets justement il y
en a d'autres encore il n'ya pas que
l'institut d'études politiques malgré
tout une question se pose de créer ce
modèle est ce que c'est véritablement
aussi au jour
l'avenir des différentes universités
l'avenir passe par ça forcément ne
serait ce que pour concurrencer les
campus à l'américaine par exemple
aujourd'hui l'avenir passe par les
regroupements
je ne sait de quoi demain sera fait une
loi nouvelle sur les universités va voir
le jour dans l'est dans les mois à venir
elle sera le fruit d'une large
concertation nationale engagée par la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
les presses la dénomination près sa
structure juridique presse pourrait
disparaître mais serait immédiatement
remplacée par une nouvelle formule nous
une nouvelle forme de regroupement puis
serait peut-être une université fédérale
qui là encore chapeauterait permettrait
à des établissements dans l'enseignement
supérieur et kolo université de
travailler ensemble
ça veut dire que chacun des
établissements va perdre son âme son
identité
nous sommes allés même nom il y aura
plus de l'université de cergy aura plus
l'université de versailles saint quentin
par exemple alors attendons la nouvelle
loi pour voir ce que ça aura
véritablement ce nouvel outil qu'est
l'université fédérale mais à titre
personnel il me semble que
ce sera à chaque université fédéral de
décider de son degré d'intégration
est-ce que cela ira jusqu'à la fusion de
tous ses membres est-ce que cela
permettra au contraire à chaque membre
de rester ce qu'il est mais vous
justement vous souhaiteriez quoi par
exemple on n'a pas mentionné mais vous
enseignez aussi à cergy oui parce que si
l'université de cergy disparaissait
devenait l'université paris-x grant west
ça changerait fondamentalement quelque
chose non chine une visite roues vont
donc notre compte si ça nous permet de
rebondir de porter encore une fois des
projets nouveaux d'être plus visible
pourquoi pas bien sûr alors justement
quelle image avez vous de ces
universités françaises a à l'heure
actuelle nous sommes allez vous poser la
question que vous soyez étudiant ou non
d'ailleurs tout le monde est concerné
une bonne image des universités qui sont
très bien côté là c'est bien sauf que
c'est un peu le bazar tout le temps au
niveau de l'administration c'est pas
forcément très bien organisées tout le
temps après il ya quand même des bons
systèmes au niveau de décompensation
pour obtenir ces semestre et c'est
qu'ils sont assez intéressants je trouve
que c'est bien
peut-être le en médecine sait pas c'est
pas bien à cause du numerus clausus qui
est trop qui est trop contraignant pour
les étudiants bon en général sont pas
mauvaises mais le manque de moyens et
puis je crois qu'il ya des problèmes
maintenant au niveau de la gestion parce
que il me semble que les postes sont
gérés par les universités au lieu d'être
gérés par bêta donc ça va poser des
problèmes
alors c'est bien mais peut mieux faire
c'est l'appréciation globale que ce soit
grand public où les étudiants qui sont
concernées et qu' ils sont confrontés à
des problèmes au quotidien
c'est un petit peu ça le fonctionnement
et le presse permet aussi de résoudre
tout ça ou ça rajoute encore une couche
supplémentaire au millefeuille non le
presse ne doit pas rajouter une couche
supplémentaire au millefeuille le presse
est un facilitateur
sinon il n'a aucune raison d'être sur
les universités je rebondis sur sur
certains des commentaires du public vous
avez interrogé
oui oui l'université c'est le bazar
c'est vrai que c'est l'image que souvent
l'université renvoi et c'est vrai que
c'est souvent le cas des universités
ce n'est pas le cas d'université plus
jeunes comme le sont celles de
versailles saint quentin ou cergy
pontoise nous avons vingt ans
d'existence et nous avons pu offrir aux
étudiants est également personae misrati
fait aux enseignants-chercheurs un
nouveau modèle universitaire qui
fonctionne voilà qui fonctionne qui est
culotté qui décomplexé qui va chasser
sur des terres qui n'était pas
nécessairement les siennes au départ et
qui permet d'offrir un nouveau visage à
l'université française
le bressan encore tout jeune puisqu'il a
été créé il ya même pas un an ce sera
bientôt son premier anniversaire déjà
deux présidentes puisque vous êtes
présente ce soir pour nous en parler
d'ailleurs vous êtes professeur de droit
et vice-présidente aussi de l'université
de cergy vous allez réduire vos
activités par ailleurs oui oui je vais
réduire mes activités mais je conserve
des activités d'enseignement et de
recherche pour rester au plus près du
terrain et pour ne pas complètement
changé de métier tout simplement un
dernier mot on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler bien évidemment sur cette
antenne et au cours des prochains 7,8
d'autres projets pour le presse
justement ce regroupement ce pôle de
recherche en dehors de l'institut
d'études politiques
alors il ya un autre projet très
stimulant qui qui qui en a encore un
petit peu au point de départ c'est la
création d'un institut de la création
portée par trois écoles prestigieuses
écoles d'architecturé de versailles du
paysage de versailles à l'école d'art de
cergy ces trois écoles ont envie de
porter des projets transversaux des
projets communs et ont envie pourquoi
pas de créer une résidence d'artistes
voilà une résidence d'accueil d'artistes
les trois directeurs que nous
rencontrons très régulièrement sont très
motivés nous également donc voilà encore
une belle illustration ce que le presque
facilité merci anne sophie barthet êtes
revenu sur ce plateau nouvelle
présidente du pres gaulle pôle de
recherche et d'enseignement supérieur
université paris grant west voilà il va
falloir s'y faire si jamais ça devenait
domination des différentes universités
vous nous l'avez dit un lieu paix
l'institut d'études politiques ouvrira
donc à la rentrée 2013 à saint germain
en laye dans un quart d'heure le 7-8
sport nous vous rendez vous sur tv fil
78 26 minutes de session consacrée
exclusivement au sport dans le
département
nous reviendrons sur les 80 ans du club
de football de trappes qui change de nom
notamment une volonté de son président
qui s'est expliqué lors d'une cérémonie
pour fêter cet anniversaire c'était ce
week-end regarder à 80 ans le trap
saint-quentin football club prend un
nouveau départ et devient l'étoile
sportive de trappes le logo présent sur
les maillots des joueurs va aussi être
modifiés avec ce nouveau site
les hommes restent mais le club prend
une autre forme un changement de
de nouveau donc de couleur orient de
couleurs que voyais autour de nous le
bleu et blanc on revient aux couleurs on
change de nom et on revient au premier
nom du club
parce que moi j'aime bien le retour aux
sources j'aime bien revenir aux ancêtres
j'aime bien revenir à ce qui a fait le
club
ce changement de nom apparaît comme un
divorce entre la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et le club
dont les subventions auraient diminué
ces dernières années suite à de descente
en division inférieure de l'équipe
première pour exemple en 2013 le club
touchera 6900 euros contre 7600 en 2012
j'abandonne le est-ce qu de saint
quentin en yvelines
vous l'aurez remarqué au passage les
abandonner on a eu moins de subventions
pour le coup de la communauté
d'agglomération on a eu des descentes en
et en excellence et en 1re div
on nous les a supprimés j'en ai pas vu
la couleur depuis depuis 2008 le club a
largement travaillé sur la formation et
sur les valeurs véhiculées par l'école
de football
résultat les équipes jeunes brille à
l'instar des moins de 15 ans qui lutte
pour le titre en division supérieure
régionale en entraînement donc le
travail parce que travail
ce qu'on leur apprend à l'école on prend
votre ça revienne c'est au foot
après c'est plus qu'un respect
solidarité travail collectif et tout mon
travail travail travail pour arriver un
jour des valeurs qui ont réuni pas moins
de 600 personnes ce samedi pour souffler
les 80 bougies du club